I have for you front and center today a
prime example of how difficult it is
even for health professionals to follow
their own advice about how not to spread
the coul virus as we are talking about
it dr. Sarah Cody was giving advice for
how to avoid contagion she correctly
says don't touch your face your hands
your eyes your mouth your nose all of
that stuff because even if you have the
virus on your hands if you avoid
touching your face and you can go and
wash your hands properly first which
should take at least 20 seconds you can
avoid self contagion you can avoid
taking the virus from your hands and
allowing it into your lungs which is
where it lives
so to speak and she says this and less
than a minute later she licks her own
fingers out in public turning the pages
of the notes that she has in front of
her this is how hard it is not to do
this check out the video today start
working on not touching your face
because one main way viruses spread is
when you touch your own mouth nose or
eyes
dr. Cody is the director of the Santa
Clara County California's Public Health
Department they have at the latest check
11 cases of the virus the press
conference was a few days ago but the
video is now getting attention because
of this this is not to make fun of her
this is a reminder of how difficult it
is not to touch one's face different
studies say people touch their faces as
much as 23 times an hour
another study says 90 times a day Donald
Trump bizarrely claimed that he hasn't
touched his face in three weeks which is
odd take a look at this mr. president is
there anything that they should be doing
differently since you think it is safe
to fly if you're a passenger you get on
that plane we've been told wash your
hands well we're always saying the
common sense of washing your hands not
touching your face ensuring that if
you've touched anything you go and wash
your hands again 20 seconds with soap
hand sanitizers also work but I think I
was very reassured to hear the airlines
talk about their cleaning procedures and
there are three levels of cleaning
procedures because I think that will be
reassuring to the American public and I
haven't touched my face in weeks and
then here's a picture of Donald Trump
touching his face during that same
briefing during which he said he hasn't
touched his face in three weeks so as
you can see it is very difficult
not just for Donald Trump but also for
public health professionals I was at a
cafe two days ago
I know I mentioned a story like this
from two weeks ago this is a different
story this is two days ago different
incident some guys sitting two seats
away from me he's coughing into the air
when talking he clearly has that cold
voice you know that voice when you're
very congested
he keeps sniffing constantly as his nose
drips are you really out at a cafe with
that right now and I know that those
symptoms are not necessarily consistent
with the virus but with everything
that's going on flu season the cool
virus all of this different stuff you go
out and you just sit on your laptop
wiping your nose touching the laptop
touching the coffee cup going over to
get water and touch
the thing that water comes out of at the
cafe going to the bathroom touching the
door the light switch the sink all of
this stuff go home what are you doing
out at a cafe you are exposing other
people and Donald Trump unfortunately
not helping making everything worse at
every opportunity denying the death-rate
calling this something that's being
politicized by the left as you can see
it's difficult even people who are
acting in good faith to do all of the
right things when it comes to this not
touch your face all of that stuff the
damage that Donald Trump is potentially
doing by continuing to spread this
disinformation is it irresponsible is an
incredible understatement as to what
Donald Trump is doing one of our
sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch don't pay thousands of dollars for
a high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of in
Cera's watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch